et on revient sur ce sommet avec nos
deux invités c'est le débat de ce soir
et nous sommes avec credo tu étais
journaliste spécialiste de l'afrique et
amadou sadio barry professeur de
philosophie chercheurs en éthique des
relations internationales bonsoir
messieurs et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france je voudrais pour
commencer vous faire réagir sur les
propos d'emmanuel macro qu'on a entendu
notre pays la france s'est construit
dans ce rapport à l'afrique qu'on ne
peut pas avoir un projet d'avenir pour
la france si elle n'assume pas sa part
d'africanité comment est ce que vous
avez accueilli ses propos du chef de
l'état traîne au tt
oui il faut dire que le chef de l'état
français conscients d'une situation
c'est qu'il faut refonder la relation
avec le continent africain et cette
refondation ne passera qu'avec l'appui
de cette génèse de cette jeunesse
dynamique qui aspire au développement de
l'afrique donc emmanuel macron ne peut
pas dire autre chose que de faire un
plaidoyer dans dans le sens de cette
refondation de cette relation france
afrique on se souvient de ce discours d'
emmanuel macron en octobre 2010 est à
ouagadougou il avait promis de
dépoussiérer les relations entre la
france et le continent il avait annoncé
aussi des actions symboliques
élaboration d'une nouvelle politique
patrimoniale en direction de l'afrique
avec la restitution d'oeuvres d'art à
leur pays d'origine il a d'ailleurs
annoncé tout à l'heure la restitution au
bénin de 26 oeuvres d'art pillés au
palais d'abonnés refonte annoncée aussi
en 2017 du franc cfa amorce d'un travail
mémoriel portant notamment sur le rôle
de la france durant le génocide des
tutsi au rwanda en 1994
amadou sadio barry ce que vous direz que
la france a aujourd'hui changé sa vision
de l'afrique
écoutez tout d'abord ont peu apprécié
les propos du président maquereau en
disant que d'un point de vue historique
aux politiques évidemment que la le
devenir de la france a été toujours lié
à devenir politique et social de
l'afrique en ce sens là dont qui a une
responsabilité de la part de paris que
de tirer les leçons d'une histoire
commune afin bien sûr de penser à un
destin commun
la france est même je dirais l'europe le
continent africain le manège général par
ailleurs il faut voir aussi que quand
même c'est cette c'est cette histoire
cette dimension historique et politique
qui a été quand même entachée par des
rapports de domination et une forme
d'asymétrie du pouvoir un pari et et ce
pré carré français en afrique et donc
est ce que là il ya changement il
faudrait voir toute la manière dont la
dimension symbolique ici la restitution
d'oeuvres d'art la question du franc cfa
par exemple pour toutes la question de
la justice môme la question de la
justice sur le plan de la mémoire notre
mémorielle comment lll structurelles
pourrait structurer une future politique
étrangère de la france ce qui est loin
d'être encore le cas et maquereau a
choisi d'inviter au camp présidents
africains c'est donc la société civile
qui a été mise à l'honneur aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'elle attend cette jeunesse
africaine de la france aujourd'hui credo
tête haute et est très concrètement non
mais il faut dire que cette jeunesse
africaine attend une sincérité une
franchise de la part de la france dans
dans ses relations avec les états
africains il faudrait que pour une fois
la france soit vraiment cessé et que la
france fasse les choses comme cela se
doit la vareille ça passe par quoi cet
oeuf franchi cette sincérité selon vous
par l'entrant parier et par une
dynamique de responsabilisation des deux
côtés donc le rapport de domination de
la france sur l'afrique devrait être
bannie et cela est vain
encourager ses relations entre les états
africains et la france et nous avons vu
et ce dernier moment le développement
que nous avons eues sur le continent
africain notamment dans la région ouest
africaine ou la france peine à à se
définir je voudrais parler cité le cas
du mali et de la guinée conakry sur le
plan politique donc il va falloir que la
france réinvente un tant soit peu la
roue mais c'était cet exercice ne
devrait être basée que sur la franchise
le respect de l'afrique et puis le
respect que je vous partager ce point de
vue amadou sadio barry vous vous
considérez que la france a manqué de
franchise et c'est peut-être ça aussi
qui a contribué à la détente la
détérioration des relations
écoutez moi je ne partage pas tout à
fait cet avis parce que ce n'est pas la
france 2 en fait de de changer la
dynamique à l'intérieur du continent
africain je pense que d'ailleurs l'idéal
du renouveau de la france trafic n'est
pas récent par son discours de la baule
ou discours de nicolas sarkozy très
controversé à dakar le coup droit qu'à
du goût donc l'idéal de renouveau en
termes de politique étrangère n'est pas
neuf et la promotion afin de permettre
la promotion des bonnes valeurs comme la
gouvernance ou en tout cas de refonder
la françafrique sincèrement sur le plan
discursif ya rien de nouveau par
ailleurs aujourd'hui mois ce qui ce qui
au jour m'interpelle c'est la manière
dont de l'intérieur de l'afrique se pose
la question des relations de domination
avec la france mais aussi la grande
puissance lorsqu'on voit par exemple que
l'afrique des politiques parce qu'il
faut distinguer trois afrique
aujourd'hui l'afrique des sociétés
civiles l'afrique des savoirs et
l'afrique des politiques à l'intérieur
de l'afrique il n'y a pas de passerelle
il ya une crise de communication une
fracture un bloc l'afrique des civils
l'afrique de savoir et l'afrique des
politiques l'afrique des politiques se
comporte depuis les indépendances d'une
manière autoritaire entretiennent de
l'intérieur des deux pays africains des
structures de diplomatie de dépendance
qui ne favorise pas une restructuration
des rapports sur le plan international
non ce n'est pas à paris de simplement
assumer sa part africaine de l'europe
une fois aussi qu'à l'intérieur des pays
africains aujourd'hui nous prennent au
sérieux la question de notre devenir
humain politique et sociale
indépendamment ajustement de leurs
relations avec le monde sait pourquoi il
faut aujourd'hui sortir me semble-t-il
momentanément du moins du concept
afrique monde pour développer une
perspective afro centré sur la manière
dont l'afrique devrait s'organiser sur
le plan politique afin de relever les
défis et les enjeux liés aux relations
internationales
ces politiques amadou sadio barry et que
vous distinguez de l'afrique des savoirs
de la société civile a été clairement
mises de côté lors de ce sommet
afrique-france quel message est envoyé
là a été renvoyé la part d' emmanuel
macron aux dirigeants africains non je
rappelle qu'il ya eu déjà un sommet sur
la relance des économies africaines ya
quelques mois donc je pense que
l'afrique politique a été à l'honneur ou
pas l'oublier non plus dans cette mise à
l'écart je pense qu'il faudrait la
relativiser mais par contre je pense que
paris depuis la fin de la guerre froide
a compris une chose justement il ya une
fracture sociale à l'intérieur de
l'afrique où l'afrique des politiques
est sourde aux revendications de justice
et d'égalité qu'exprime sa jeunesse et
surtout ses intérêts que la chine ben
bella feu lune sàrl et bachir diagne
développe aujourd'hui un savoir au sein
de l'afrique absolument remarquable
pensons de la pensée mais les politiques
les politiques publiques en afrique ne
sont pas malheureusement informé par le
savoir et je pense que la diplomatie
française avec le sentiment anti
français
la difficulté l'opération barkan et tout
ça aujourd'hui est conscient de cette
fracture qui travaillent le continent
blaze indépendance donc il ya là le
semble-t-il une manière de procéder à
travers le symbolique pour réaménager la
politique étrangère de la france en
afrique est toute la question je
terminais de savoir est-ce que ce détour
symbolique que justement après une
mutation politique c'est ce qui me
paraît tout à fait difficile parce que
on peut bien restituer les oeuvres d'art
mais tout à fait avaliser le coût de
l'eau à coacher which had il soutenir
des régimes autoritaires au congo
brazzaville et aussi lutter avec la
russie pour essayer d'imposer un premier
ministre en centrafrique donc les deux
peuvent s'intégrer dans une logique où
la france joue le symbolique mais aussi
et c'est quand même de prendre en
considération l'environnement
international pour essayer de mieux se
repositionner en afrique où rappelons le
sont exclues visité est davantage
contesté crédo tetteh risque à vous dire
et vous aussi qu'aujourd'hui il faut est
ce que c'est important de faire la
distinction entre la société civile
africaine et ses dirigeants est ce qu'il
est aussi une prise de risque au plan
diplomatique de la part des manuels
macro à ne pas avoir invité ses
dirigeants africains
donc je crois que le président français
a le choix des invités les chefs d'état
africains ou dont messi l'a fait
justement ce choix de dialoguer avec la
jeunesse avec la sté civile donc c'est
qu'il est conscient que lâcheté civile
regorge de potentialités et il faut
aller à la source pour essayer de
diagnostic est le véritable problème
m'ont beaucoup d'amateurs il l'a dit
tout de suite il ya l'afrique politique
d'enseignants que au niveau des chefs
d'état ya des décisions qui sont prises
qui
globalement ne prennent pas en compte
les aspirations des
désorganisations des civils aux nouveaux
pays au niveau afrique donc il va
falloir diagnostiquer le mal à la racine
et c'est de voir comment est ce que les
sociétés civiles africaines s'exprime
rené weiler réel besoin pour essayer de
faire quelque chose de potable avec elle
donc là c'est lui d'impérieuse nécessité
pour la france mais chef de l'état
français de dialoguer avec la société
civile ça lui permettra d'ouvrir
grandement les yeux les oreilles pour
recevoir disons-le et les compléments
d'information ou bien les propositions
de ces sociétés civiles et de ses
organisations de jeunesse qui sont assez
dynamiques qui joue au niveau du
continent africain ne sont pas
nécessairement entendue par le dirigeant
et c'est à destination de cette société
civile africaine que la france va
débloquer un fonds d'innovation pour la
démocratie ce sont les termes employés
un employé un fonds de 30 millions
d'euros pour soutenir cette jeunesse
notamment africaines est ce que cela
aussi ça participe amadou sadio barry
est ce que ça participe concrètement à
ces nouveaux rapports entre la france et
le continent africain rappelons aussi
que ce fonds d'innovation pour la
démocratie aura une gouvernance
indépendante
lui je pense que quand même il faut
saluer certains chefs la crise est en
cela qu à celle d'un biladi enfin a pu
dire que le président macron à une vos
regards sur le continent s'est pas tout
à fait fort de la part du prochain bébé
par ailleurs les fonds des de la
démocratie à je veux dire les etats-unis
ont déjà le cas similaire avec le m6 et
le millenium challenge corporation
mais on constate dans les dents dans la
dynamique politique et les logiques
parce qu'il faut le dire encore c'est à
dire que le changement en politique
étrangère n'est pas simplement due à des
facteurs internes à l'afrique c'est
aussi à des facteurs externes la lutte
que j'ai bondi quand les grandes
puissances les rivalités aujourd'hui en
termes de contrôle du continent que même
des de nouvelles puissances comme les
émirats arabes unis le qatar et mhi
serait là aujourd'hui déploie sur le
continent donc oui et un fonds dead que
soutenir une jeunesse active et c'est
vrai tout à l'heure il y à just et
civils paloc de pays africains qui est
quand même et ce qui est dynamique en
termes de promotion des valeurs
humanistes et de la bonne gouvernance
dont là dessus se font là est bienvenue
mais la question c'est de savoir quel
pourrait être le lien entre ce fauve la
démocratie et justement les
transformations sur le plan politique
c'est là que la grande question parce
que je pense qu'il ne faudrait pas
simplement rester à cette dimension
symbolique
l'histoire des relations internationales
montrent que les fonds d'êtres humains
peuvent être instrumentalisés dans une
perspective qui vise à soutenir des
dictatures et là dessus il faut voir
quand même que le plus la position
actuellement où le sommet ait lieu enfin
lieu pardon vous avez quand même une
crise avec le mali et l'algérie honda
les mois précédents il ya eu le soutien
à le sur le coup d'état constitutionnel
au tchad donc il ya quand même là des
éléments qui montrent que on sait pas le
phénomène à l'intérieur de l'afrique qui
peut conduire une transformation des
relations avec la france c'est aussi
l'environnement international que
malheureusement l'afrique des politiques
n'arrivent pas à contrôler il n'arrive
pas à penser il ya une crise de
l'imaginaire une crise de l'imaginaire
du politique en afrique depuis les
indépendances il faut aussi penser un
tout dernier mot assez rapidement si
vous le voulez bien avec vos credo tt
pour conclure est ce que vous pensez que
ce faux mais comme tant d'autres peut
cette fois-ci conduire réellement à
l'amélioration des relations entre
l'afrique et la france non et je ne
voudrais pas être pessimiste je suis
optimiste et de bon résolution qui sont
sortis de ce sommet seront mises en
oeuvre et notamment dans la gestion de
ces fonds de 30 millions d'euros sur
trois ans donc on voudrait engager les
ceux qui vont rester au dessus qui vont
siéger au sein de ce comité a élaboré
des critères assez clair objectif est
qu'ils puissent bénéficier aux
organisations de la cité civile qui est
9e sur les différents terrains pour la
bonne gouvernance parce que la bonne
gouvernance c'est comme le développement
la basse et à la base donc il va falloir
essayer d'ouvrir les yeux à nos
dirigeants sur ce qui ne va pas et avoir
également savoir le faire et à voir la
manière de pouvoir faire des
propositions donc ce fonds pour la
démocratie et la bienvenue mais je
formule le voeu que ça soit un fort qui
puisse amener un rythme dynamique de
propositions merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cet échange ce soir
crédo tetteh journaliste spécialiste de
l'afrique amadou sadio barry est
professeur de philosophie chercheurs en
éthique des relations internationales
merci à tous les deux il ya bientôt
servir les français